mmm it's a lot going through my mind
like I feel like I kept it real from you
since they would mm-hmm I personally
feel that you left out who you really
are
diamond I am I don't have to disclose
information watch you wig does it keep
slide
I'm gonna do that she fell in love with
in the pods that can't see my life
without you I love you see a content
like I'm so happy that to see him and
happy that he's here and we were able to
mend our friendship as well as
relationship and I love that he
apologized to me and like I said to I
apologize and I won't apologize again
because I feel like I might have not
done it there but I feel like for him
that Eva come out and you know people
are rejecting him and I just I've never
won anybody to attacked him or you just
feel that I'm attacking you so I do want
to apologize for that as well because
now that I'm looking at it and seeing
what my actions were I'm like maybe I
should have approached it differently
and so I kind of looking back like now
there's certain ways to say things you
know and put it in a certain way in a
certain perspective so I feel like I
could possibly had led on to possibly a
little argument just by how I approached
it so I do apologize about that as well
thanks this is why I don't deal with
I don't deal with women like you yo-yo
the blow-up at the pool I totally
disrespected her is something that I
felt really bad about and it took me
some time to even find out how do I even
fix it or I apologize for it so I have
to apologize to you again because I feel
like I I'm apologising like daily that's
how bad I feel about it and I want it
for today to be the start of something
beautiful that doesn't have to be us be
engaged to each other that doesn't have
to be us getting married but can we at
least come to a common ground of
forgiveness and try to see what happens
I think one thing that people need to
understand that I have never been with a
bisexual man I'm not in that community
and I do respect that community however
but although I just don't know like a
lot of things about it that's why I came
to approach him with questions and I
wasn't trying to like attack him but I
wasn't trying to make him feel the
little or feel like he should never came
out it's just matter of fact of just
understanding and knowing what that is
and I feel like a lot of people don't
you know we respect the community but a
lot of people just don't know how
certain people act in the way or how
they their sexual preference like we
don't this is not what we experience
every day as in people and we're in a
heterosexual community this particular
experiment was about finding love
and we all know and if we don't I'm here
to let you know it's very hard for fluid
people because we get backlash from
heterosexuals and from gays so it's kind
of like you're stuck in the middle I
felt like in this experiment had I gone
in in the first day and say hey I'm
fluid that it would have trickled back
to the girls side as everything that we
said on Days trickle back and and no one
would give me a chance to get to know me
from my heart so that was like the whole
reasoning behind that and then also TV
life versus real life in real life I
need to know for sure that years before
we have that conversation because you
may use it against me it's been used
against people before I've been
ridiculed bash even right now it's 2020
and I'm getting death threats for
sharing my truth as a fluid man on
television so I just think that I was
being protective of myself and finally
put myself before other people like I'm
trying to take her on a date the answer
is no right now but I think that you
know things take time like and if if she
never decides to go on a date with me I
have I was engaged to someone that was
amazing at one point in my life so
that's enough I feel like why I drew the
line it was that I was disrespect I'm
sorry to keep bringing this up I was
disrespected and like I was explaining
to him before that you know I had one
guy in my relationship I ever tried to
suspect me and I was it I was done and
coming from a family that I have seen
verbal and physical abuse that now -
he's not here anymore it's let's talk
about it just experience in those
moments you know I don't ever want to
put myself in something like doesn't
saying that you would do that yeah yeah
I'm not saying accountant's aggressive
but it led to that and it started off a
verbal abuse and she's right here so
just certain lately like when they say
something about going through things you
don't know and they just reiterated some
things that I told myself as a woman I
wouldn't never tolerate I would never
talk about nobody caught me I might lean
if you're gonna be with me and down with
me you should always have my back and
you should always be expect me I'm
always gonna get people to come
left or right talk about me that I
should never question you gonna do that
to me I just feel so misunderstood in
that scene honestly and I would never
change like like I in my mind I didn't
call her out her name in my mind I made
her a reference that put her into a box
of women who were stereotypical and
ignorant based on the things that were
being said to me that was never it was
never like oh she's that why would I
want to marry someone that I felt that
about you know so I just want to
continue to clean it up because I feel
like she's still processing that but for
me like that's not what it was it's not
that weird that just we just thought we
don't know about it no but when
someone's saying I should have known it
change well you've made a comment that
they didn't show when you were like I
should have known you were gay because
you knew so many of beyonce lyrics
that's what I'm referring to that's why
in the scene people say when I say oh no
like it's cool like have your moment we
spoke about that yeah cuz you also
degraded me we hit we all both said a
lot of things that was below the belt so
it's not like I already said like I said
some things I know I said some things
and he said some things too that wasn't
showing on there as well but it was a
build-up and for him right you said
something about like my hair like how I
look and all these other things which is
what the experiment was about is not
judging a person on the character
outside so you not only attacked my
character you also attacked my parents
it wasn't just that was like after the
build-up nobody but it still it doesn't
it's not a skin so you still spoke about
it even was I don't I'm not here today
she's right she right point fingers I'm
here just to say my truth and say that
you know this is why I chose this and
why I would not be moving forward with
that situation yeah and I think they're
like what ideas like just even sharing
like my history of dating like no one
else on the show was like sharing their
sexual history or anything so for anyone
to think like that it was like okay well
that's all there was no like let's be
very clear it was like major and totally
different and I feel like you know like
I'm treated different
like I won't give up on love like you
know it's him you know what I'm saying I
belong so much from it and it's only
gonna help me navigate my next situation
better yeah I believe love is my as you
see we have two beautiful couples that
are still together they just give me
hope as like for my future relationships
or relationships shall I say to find my
king but I do want to piggyback what he
said I know you've mentioned that you
feel like you coming out that's the
reason why were not together
it's not a bad if you his fluid is the
fact that you lied and it was disrespect
so I do want to let you know it is a lie
but you're not being honest in the
beginning so okay but like I was saying
so I won't so like I was saying I want
I do believe love is blind and I do have
hope for everyone and although our
parents did not work out its together I
do know that it can help us with
somebody else
don't take my experience and be like no
I would never do this whatever no I want
people to think that I want people to
know that although it happened for me it
doesn't it can have a real
[Music]